just how concerned should we be about
the two human cases of bird flu in
Cambodia we know they occurred in the
south of the country in prevent Province
an 11 year old girl died and her father
also tested positive for the h5n1 virus
but he's well genetic testing identified
the girls virus as an endemic variant
called
2321c but the scientists leading the
analysis has now told Sky News that the
bird flu virus had mutations that helped
it adapt to human cells
there are some indications that
um you know this virus has gone through
a human so what we have to understand
is that when a virus gets into a new
host they are very promiscuous they
change very quickly and they do adapt
but that doesn't mean the virus can
spread between people at least not yet
it latches on to a type of cell receptor
which is only found deep down in our
lungs for it to transmit easily between
people it has to mutate to Target a
different receptor found on cells in our
nasal passages that's what regular
winter flu does the cells are not only
easier to infect but a cloud of virus is
released with every breath but Dr
Carlson warns the world must closely
track the virus and work on test kits
and vaccines just in case it changes
it is concerning that it's gone Global
so quickly and I think the entire
influenza Community as well as the
public health and Animal Health
communities are quite concerned about it
um obviously
in the UK
um in all of Europe as well as North
America South America
um there's been massive poultry
infections there's been spillovers into
mammals
um and each one of those spillovers into
mammals is a concern
here the UK Health Security Agency
reported a human case of bird flu in
January 2022 and so far this winter
there have been more than 3 000
exposures to the H5 N1 virus and people
working closely with sick Birds none of
them tested positive Health officials
are also analyzing a small number of
samples taken from patients with
flu-like symptoms to check the virus
isn't spreading below the radar it's not
just Cambodia a risk the next pandemic
could start anywhere